most men find most women to be at least  somewhat attractive in contrast women on  average view 80 of men as below average  in attractiveness another study found  that on the dating app tinder men liked  more than 60 of the female profiles they  viewed while women liked only four and a  half percent of male profiles i didn't  realize that 80 percent of men as below  average that's quite off it is because  you know you would think like 50 right  it's sort of like 50 above and 50 below  but to have 80 percent rated below is  pretty grim because of the increased  risk women carry they tend to be  choosier about their partners in  contrast men are less discerning studies  of online dating for example find that